No young was a student of niches you see.
And he was also,
I would say at the very
astute critic of nature,
he was educated by Freud and Freud.
Freud,
I suppose in some sense
started to collate,
collate the information that we had
pertaining to the notion that people lived
inside a dream.
You know,
it was Freud who really popularized
the idea of the unconscious mind.
And we take this for granted to such a
degree today that we don't understand how
revolutionary the idea was.
Like with what's happened with Freud is
that we've taken all the marrow out of
his bones so to speak,
less the husk behind.
And you know,
now when we think about Freud,
we just think about the husk because
that's everything that's been discarded.
But so much of what he discovered as
part of our popular conception now
including the idea that your perceptions
and your actions and your thoughts are
all,
um,
what would you say?
Informed and shaped by unconscious
motivations that are not part of your
voluntary control.
And that's a very,
very strange thing.
It's one of the most unsettling things
about the psychoanalytic theories.
Cause the psychoanalytic
theories or something like
you're a loose collection of
living sub personalities each with its
own set of motivations and perceptions
and emotions and rationales,
all of that,
and you have limited control over that.
So you're like a plurality of,
of,
of internal personalities that's
loosely late into a unity.
You know that because you can't
control yourself very well,
which is one of Hume's objections to
Nietzsche's idea that we could create our
own values.
So young didn't believe that,
especially not after interacting with
Freud because he saw that human beings
were affected by things that were deeply,
deeply effected by things that were
beyond their conscious control.
And no one really knows how
to conceptualize those things.
You know,
the cognitive psychologists
think about them in some senses,
computational machines
and the ancient people,
I think thought of them as God's,
although it's more complex than that,
like rage would be a god.
Mars,
the god of rage.
That's the thing that possesses
you when you're angry,
you know,
it has a viewpoint and it,
it it,
it says what it wants to say.
And that might have very little to do
with what you want to say when you're
being sensible and it
doesn't just inhabit.
You had inhabits everyone and it lives
forever and it even inhabits animals.
And so it's this transcendent
psychological entity
that inhabits the body
politic light,
like a thought in habits,
the brain.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's very strange way of thinking,
but it certainly,
it certainly has its merits and so,
and those things,
well in some sense,
those are daddies.